this one is closely related to what
we've been looking at it's still under
the heading of reverse chain rule but it
kind of gets a new name because it looks
a little bit different so we're gonna
talk about that in a second right for
this next bit everything I think I want
to do should fit on this board so if
you're able to then right as we go and
keep up but if not you'll be fine to
just concentrate on what is happening
and just have your mind fully engaged
and what you need to have written down
you can copy it all the way at the end
so we will have the time we'll make it
okay so have a look at this integral
with me again you're staying to get to
this point where like the example I
showed you over here there's a lot of
stuff to keep in your brain you're like
okay this is a complicated object I
can't just look it and say I know
exactly what that is so what we do is we
introduce kind of helps little sort of
algebraic tricks that sort of you
separate out the work into multiple
steps which are smaller on their own
there's more steps but they're smaller
steps for they're easier for your brain
to handle okay
this little trick is called substitution
which sounds strange because you know
how to do substitution this is not a new
skill but we're going to apply it in a
new context okay
so we're going to introduce a whole new
letter into this this is all in terms of
X's right now your integrand is in X's
you're integrating with respect to X but
I'm going to change all of that in order
to make it a little bit easier to deal
with to basically give myself an easier
integrand that I can just look at and I
can just integrate it straight away okay
so here's what I'm going to do I'm going
to introduce the substitution and in all
the cases where it matters you'll be
given what this substitution is unless
it's like blindingly obvious and you'll
get that with practice but often the
question will literally say let you use
just the most common letter for
substitution let u equal then they
provide you with an expression in this
case it's going to be 5x squared plus 1
the thing underneath the square root
okay now if I'm about to change
everything from X's to use then I can't
integrate
with respect to X anymore right it
doesn't make sense you're trying to mix
up letters right we saw this with when
we were doing volumes do you remember
this we would say the volume is equal to
from here to here of this guy right and
by the way to remember what this
represented what kind of objects are we
adding up these are cylinders pi radius
squared
there's the height okay but we know you
can't actually do very much with this
you actually have to get rid of that Y
and replace it with something like you
know X minus 1 and once everything is in
terms X's hooray I can integrate ok same
deal here I'm about to change everything
to use so this DX it cannot stay around
okay I have to get rid of it somehow
here's the sort of fatty calculus tricks
we use to get rid of it DX is up here in
integration but they also appear in
differentiation and therefore I can use
this as sort of my launchpad right have
a look at this like if you want imagine
it is y y equals something do you wanna
do X this is the same into
differentiation you always do I just
want to differentiate this expression
over here
what should I end up with it's just 10 X
10 X on its own yeah okay now what I'm
about to do you have to be a little bit
careful with I'm gonna move some symbols
around just as if there were normal
symbols but you just have to be mindful
of the fact that this to you and this DX
they're not just like any letters right
like we're doing we're mucking around
with these infinitesimally small objects
it's a little bit strange to interact
with these but I can for the purposes of
this question treat this guy just like a
regular fraction so watch this I can
multiply both sides by this DX over here
because in this context I can treat it
just like a regular factor I should get
this over on the right hand side is that
okay in this context this is fine have a
look at what you've got on the right
hand side though think back to that
previous question this is very similar
to something over here it's not exactly
the same but it's so close it might as
well be I have 10 X DX over here I have
just one X DX you see that you see how
these things are being multiplied
together so I could rearrange them if I
wanted to so I don't want ten of them I
just want one so what shall I do to both
sides I'll divide by 10 that leaves me
with this on the left-hand side and with
this on the right-hand side okay now if
you look carefully and you're some
colors for this card right over here and
over here I have accounted for
everything in the original question if I
just use these two pieces I can get rid
of all the x's and replace them with
things to do with you instead so let's
do that integral of this X and this DX
I'm going to replace them with 1/10 do
you it's just a straight substitution a
tenth and a D you is that okay
I've used this line over here how am I
gonna use this well I'll end up with the
square root of what it's just just
that's just you isn't it square root of
U that okay so look all right all the
X's are gone or replace reviews let me
make this even neater for us what have I
done I've created a much simpler version
of this question this was the point of
doing the substitution if you forgot
about the fact that it was an unusual
letter you're used to seeing X's the
letter doesn't really matter right you
could do X to the 1/2 DX you could do t
to the 1/2 DT you could do dhruv to the
1/2 deed roof I don't know what to move
to the 1/2 would be but I could do it
then well it's just a label okay it's
just a label so I can integrate this
this is really easy right that one-tenth
is going to hang around the front
this is indefinite so what happens to
this one I'm going to do to the power
adds plus one and then what do I do with
that new power I denied
is that okay did I do that right it's
indefinite so the thing I need to add on
the end is plus C let's tidy up these
numbers a little bit ten times three on
two is 15 isn't it that's you ^ 3 on 2
on 15 and at last I've gotten to a point
where well the integration is done which
was the hard part
it's in terms of use though the original
question didn't have you in it I
introduced that so I'm just going to put
it back to what it was before which is
5x squared plus 1 to the power of 3 on
10 okay now I will leave as an exercise
to the reader that you can check very
easily that this is correct because if I
integrate it to get to this then I
should be able to differentiate and I
should land straight back then go ahead
and test this actually it will take you
like two lines max okay so all of the
magic is happening over here this step
over here makes the process at least in
terms of the working it makes it longer
but what it does is it renders the
original question much easier to deal
with like you just get end up with
something like that which is nice and
neat okay so we call this integration by
substitution we're not done with this
idea yet we'll have a look at harder
version of it particularly when you
don't have indefinite integrals when you
have definite ones but this is a new
enough idea that I don't want to bombard
you with that just yet